it's time for forgiveness it's time for
new beginnings
[Music]
what's your secret Sofia how do you
manage to pull off playing the role of a
teenager when you are so much older in
real life how is it that you and your
co-stars look young enough to attend our
dung trap we were shocked when we found
out how old you guys really are it looks
like you all have your skin routines
down pat the actors from The Descendants
films aren't the only ones who play
characters who are way younger than them
in real life this is a pretty common
thing in the Disney verse here are the
Disney Channel actors who have the
biggest age gaps between their true age
and that of the characters they play
Sophia Carson we all know and love
Sophia as Evie in descendants one two
and three she plays a young lady who is
in charge of her destiny but in real
life she's much older than her character
yep you heard that right Sophia is 26
years old but Evie is only supposed to
be 16
that's a 10-year age difference Sophia
is so youthful nobody seems to question
it sure she seems very mature for a 16
year old in the films after all she does
have her own castle in d3 he might be
surprised to discover that she's not the
only descendants cast member who is way
older than their character keep watching
to find out which d3 character has the
biggest age gap ashley tisdale this High
School Musical 3 star had a 6 year
difference from the character she played
in the Disney Channel original movie in
the film she played a teenager who is
graduating high school but in real life
Ashley was 23 years old but she had no
problem playing a teenager chalk it up
to the good genes and she wasn't the
only HSN star who was 6 years older than
their character thank you next Lucas
Grabeel
Lucas played the twin brother to
Ashley's character Sharpay Evans
shar-peis brother Ryan obviously
graduated high school at the same time
as his twin sister which would have made
them both about 17 years old but just
like his co-star he was much old
than his character he was 23 years old
at the time they totally looks like
teenagers maybe they did a ton of yoga
to keep them looking so young but that's
not even the biggest age difference we
found in the High School Musical cast
everybody loves a good Jessica Monica
Coleman do you guys remember taylor
mckessie from high school musical well
you might not believe this but she was
almost 28 years old by the time the
third movie came out that's an 11 year
difference did she even remember what
high school musical was like after all
that time
well she must have because she nailed
the part impressive Monique Jason Earles
this age gap is pretty mind-blowing as
well Jason Earles play the role of Miley
Cyrus's 16 year old brother in Hannah
Montana but in real life he was 29 years
old
that would make him 15 years older than
Miley's character who was 14 at the time
that's a pretty big jump
seriously Jason what skin cream are you
using we want some ASAP Tiffany Thornton
in Disney Channel's sunny with a chance
tiffany played the role of the teenage
character tawny heart but in reality she
was much older than her character at 23
years old Tiffany was playing the role
of a kid while living the life of an
adult she got engaged to her boyfriend
the same year sunny with the chance
debuted Tiffany went on to play the role
of tawny on the sunny spinoff so random
Tiffany was actually married and
expecting her first child when the last
episode of the show aired in 2012
Garret Clayton this teen beach movie
star was far from a teen when he shot
the phone he was in his 20s when the
first movie came out in 2013 and he was
still able to pull off that teen look in
the sequel two years later but he did
have to take other measures to be
perceived as younger his reps told him
the name he was born with sounded too
old what his birth name is Garry Michael
Clayton which gives off a more mature
vibe so he changed it to Garrett Clayton
and the rest is history
Dylan play fair this is an in star
played the role of the lovable clueless
Gill son of Gaston free right he's
supposed to be a villain kid but in
reality he is all grown up
can you guess his real age if you
guessed 27 you're absolutely right this
baby-faced pirate was somehow able to
pull off the villain kid look with ease
you would never know that he is at least
ten years older than the character he
played in the movies and now for the
star who wins the prize for the biggest
age difference between actor and
character in The Descendants movies you
know him as Chad charming the son of
Cinderella and Prince Charming Jedediah
Goodacre this character is young enough
to attend our azam prep which means he
should be no more than 17 years old but
the actor who played him is way older
than that Jedediah must have the
Fountain of Youth in his backyard
because he is actually 30 years old that
makes him a full 13 years older than his
descendents character I say we go back
to my place they maybe binge watching TV
did you guys have any idea he was that
much older than the rest of the cast who
we didn't have the slightest clue and
that's the end of our video whose age
were you most shocked about tell us in
the comments and don't forget to hit
that subscribe button and give this
video a big thumbs up thanks for
watching the things we'll see you next
time
[Music]